[Music]
you
dear friends welcome back to this
lecture on memory continuing from the
last class we were discussing about long
term memory in the upcoming lectures
we'll discuss on the types of long term
memory which are available for humans
and we'll see what are the properties of
this memory how do they function in
several the qualities of these memories
so let's begin this lecture on semantic
memory now if you remember from the last
class I discussed about the way
long-term memory is organized and so
what we saw in the last class was that
long-term memory had two separate
distinctions so two separate parts of it
and I also explained a little bit about
the distinctions of these two parts so
these parts are the declarative and the
procedural type of memories nor
declarative if you remember from the
last class declarative type memories are
those memories which have conscious
which have conscious awareness people
are consciously aware so when performing
this memory people know what they're
doing and so they basically take part in
these memories consciously remember are
well aware of what is happening and so
memories of events memories of facts
memories of other kind of memories which
you know that you are acting on or
you're thinking of declarative in nature
and so the declarative memories are then
divided into two parts also declarative
procedural memory can also be subdivided
in terms of explicit so some books were
talk of declarative memories as an
explicit memory and the procedural
memory as an implicit memory and this
explicit implicit is basically dependent
on the amount of consciousness that you
are putting onto it so whether you are
aware so if you are aware of a
particular memory type it is declarative
if you are unaware of a particular
memory when it is functioning this is
the implicit type and so there is a
debate on these two types of memories of
declarative and procedural or two
memories area now looking at the
subdivisions the declarative memory is
divided into two subdivisions we have
the semantic memory and we have the
episodic memory and so the upcoming few
lectures will be basically focusing on
the semantic and episodic now procedural
type memory where people are not aware
of that they are accessing the memory is
basically implicit and basically visit
in nature is something we shall not
discuss here in this particular
introduction our two cycle cognitive
psychology class but I will give you the
distinction of what type it is further
divided into so we have habits we have
classical conditioning and we also have
priming now if you look at the earlier
lectures I have briefly defining these
habits classical conditioning in priming
and what is the meaning of that and also
about semantic and episodic so quickly
create look into what it is so
procedural type memories are those
memories which you are not aware of that
they exist but they take place for
example riding a bicycle playing a piano
typing on the keyboard and so on and so
forth so you do it with such less
intention that you are not consciously
aware Petunia doing it and declarative
memories are those where your functions
arise or thinking about a particular
event
about the particular fact in life
verifying and only verifying a rule or
several other kind of memories where you
are aware of it is what is declarative
within the semantic episodic distinction
semantic memories are those memories
which are based on facts whose knowledge
arithmetic properties things about about
objects facts about objects which you
can verify color shape that kind of a
thing is semantic memory so when I say I
know what an appellees are questions
like who was Christopher Columbus or
questions like who is a Donald Trump
now where is US where is Europe or facts
like two plus two equals to four what is
the meaning of addition sign what is the
meaning of a division sign what is the
integral what is an indefinite integral
and that kind of facts which are either
arithmetic rules facts in life or facts
and knowledge are go all semantics in
knowledge or semantics in type
declarative memories are those memories
which we basically go ahead and remember
about events so your first day of school
your first graduation the graduation 90
the prom night that you had after
graduation
your first farewell of school the second
farewell obviously you would have been
to ten interest class both so two favors
to think about first day in college
first day in school any party in your
life all those kinds of even say you're
personally aware of or where you're
personally part of is basically what
you're at Masonic memory would consist
of now in the procedural type you have
habits habits are those facts which
basically are something which happens
automatically so habits like habits of
scratching yourself a bit of touching
your hair
at age point of time habits of twitching
your nose
there are several habits that people
have and these are automatic kind of
things automatic kind of act that people
do but they are not aware of
similarly in classical conditioning what
happens is that doing something not
knowing that you are doing that
particular act or behavior for a
particular reward is something called
classical conditioning so buying
something because something else is free
with it or thinking positively about
someone because something has been
offered to you for thinking positively
about that person is classical
conditioning in priming of brief kind of
information or a brief information is
presented to you and this information
leads you to basically go ahead and
access memory or verify a particular
fact
so before knowing someone is some kind
of information is provided to you very
distinctly or very implicitly about this
person your first impression of the
person would be change according to it
and so that is what is priming so in
this particular lecture will be mainly
focusing on the semantic memory so what
we look into is what is semantic memory
got out of the basic what are the basic
steps of formation of semantic memory
what are the various tools which I use
for accessing it other models which
explain it the various underlying
limitations of the various model and
what does it explain what does it do for
us and so on and so forth so that's what
we'll be looking in this first lecture
let's continue with our idea of semantic
memory in the next coming lecture we'll
also look on a part of episodic memory
or racial memory so then what is obvious
to us is that people have a lot of
knowledge they hold on to a lot of
knowledge
this world or about this world with them
at each point of time so from the time
when you are born to the time to the
present time you have a lot of
information with you about the world
around you about the environment around
you what people around you and so they
are stored in your in your personal
memory and most of this information
which is stored may be personal and may
not be personally mature for example
something which doesn't concern you
facts like Mary's America doesn't
concern you and so it is stored and
there will be at the facts thing
something about when is a birthdate or
what is the color that you like but also
stored on to it so a lot of memory is
stored a lot of information is told in
your memory now these contains as I said
knowledge relating to definitions of
words arithmetic facts procedures
historical and scientific journal of
acknowledge and so on and so forth and
so most of these are cemented in nature
so any memory which is not concerning
you or concerning yourself into it or
doesn't form around you a semantic
knowledge so facts that can be tested
facts that can be verified fact that you
learn from people around you and facts
that are helpful for you in terms of
making you leave this world are
basically semantic in nature now
basically then how is memory arranged
what is the way memory arranged and one
of the earliest metaphor or what is the
earliest analog of how memory is
arranged is basically the bookshelf
metal metaphor so it's and this is the
semantic memory that I am talking about
so knowledge facts ideas arithmetic
properties and all those how are they
arranged one of the basic metaphor ever
and the primary metaphor is the
bookshelf so basically it's believed
that just like when you go to a library
how do you search a book so the best way
if you have been to a library nowadays
there are computer programs like
Lipsey's which actually help you into
finding a book but if you go to an old
library where they don't
this software's for helping you to how
find out how to locate a book you would
find out that there are still the old
methods of finding a book and how does
that work
so you basically go to particular desk
which is called the naming catalog so it
could be either a naming catalog and/or
a place catalog so naming catalog would
have names of authors and a place
catalog or title catalog will have
titles about us so you choose one of
this catalog and so let's say I choose
the title catalog or the subject catalog
so I choose that let's say I choose the
naming catalog now suppose I am looking
for a particular book I'm looking for
the book Alice in Wonderland and so if I
am looking for Alice in Wonderland
I'll have to search from something
called the a so I look for a of all the
books which are available in a and
within a there will be several
variations from a a to a a set and so
within a you will have several books a
be evil has several books a see EULA
several books and so when you go to that
Alice in Wonderland is a hey L so I'll
go to Al and then I'll search for the
particular book so within Al you will
have lots of books so I come to the
basic book within that particular book
also Alice in Wonderland there will be
several versions of it the abridged
version the main was and the total
version and so I'll look at that and
then there will be something called a
calling number or basically an accession
number and I'll look at the accession
number then I will go to the row the
main library where books are stacked and
then I also search for I look for the
particular accession number because
books are arranged according to
oxidation numbers and look for that
particular three-digit four-digit
accession number and I'll find that
version of the book so this is basically
how the bookshelf metaphor really works
it is believed that semantic memory also
follows a metaphor like this this is how
most items or most facts are in a
semantic memory so information in memory
they consist of knowledge of
specific events and memory for general
knowledge as I said this being most
information in memory will be either
personal or will be either general
knowledge think it is of how
generalities is facts about general
knowledge are stored and so mostly the
follower metaphor which is equal to
bookshelf no the fact theory is that the
question that do we have this kind of a
distinction in declarative memory now in
the last class we saw that the debate
over the existence of procedural and
seam and declarative memory in this
particular lecture we'll see our debate
or we will discuss a debate on the
existence of cement again episodic
memory so whether there are two kinds of
memory and if they are then what is the
way in which they're arranged and what
are their properties so and filming in
1972 1983 he argued that Altium
conveyance of two stores basically the
episodic in the semantics store which
are which are very highly distinct they
are distinct stores because one store
stores facts knowledge and that kind of
a things you don't need you to think
about it think about anything or think
about any personal relevance information
there and the other store is the
declarative store where I am sorry the
episodic store where you have
information which is personal in content
and so you argue that these are the two
kind of store an interesting fact here
the fact is that that piece Adak store
can not exist without the semantic
source or some kind of information is
always borrowed from the semantic store
and when we end this section will also
talk about something called scripts and
schemas and six key mother scripts of
the way of how the semantic store
interferes are basically aids the
episodic store now that Pixar extort I
think of the episodic store when I am
thinking about a particular party or a
particular your graduation night
thinking about you
night if that is what I am thinking
about it has a lot of informational to
it what information follows a certain
rule or follows a certain structure and
this structure is so when you think
about a party you think about a rupee no
what happens in a party and that is what
basically scripts are scripts are schema
it's a basically a schema for proteins
we'll come to that
so basically there are certain steps
through a party and that is what you
tend to remember in that particular way
you tend to remember
so although the facts may vary from
person to person but the graduation
night the what happens in a graduation
night would be similar to most people
and that is what a script is all about
and the idea that this is what happens
in a graduation night you go there you
do something you do a little bit of
dancing lot of chatting mr. and mrs.
miss graduation is is named then you
drink the punch or whatever you do have
a little fun and maybe dance with your
lady and then you come back and this is
the kind of schema which is there or
this is the kind of structure of a
graduation party which is there and so
this is what is going to happen and this
is what happens in a particular schema
in a in a particular even and in
particularly in the episodic store this
is how the schema really works so as I
was telling you that within the episodic
memory of your graduation what to do and
what not to there will be several
schemas and these schemas are part of
the semantic memory so whatever you do
in your graduation party is basically an
extension of the semantic memory so
episodic memories have to have semantic
knowledge or semantic facts embedded
into it but not the reverse case
semantic memories may not have things
from the episodic store so basically
when you when I'm talking to you when
I'm asking you what an Apple is you will
need not remember
we will learn the word Apple or the
first time you were shown an apple and
told or an apple is but then with
semantic memory this is the independence
that you have but with episodic memory
this is not the independence that you
have you when you describe an apple you
have to know what an apple is or what
defines an apple by the apple a certain
shape certain color that kind of a thing
has to be there but you can also define
or tell me the first time you heard the
word Apple that is basically Episode II
knowledge so let's look at the
distinction or the episodic and semantic
memory and so quick distinctions
episodic memory has it said it enables
people to travel back in time and become
consciously aware of witnessing or
participating in events in earlier life
so basically what episode of memory does
is that it gives you this confidence it
gives you that freedom to travel back in
time so here I can travel in time and so
trying travel has not been invented but
with memory studies you do travel back
in time to that particular event it
becomes live on to you so episodic
memory gives you this particular freedom
to travel back in time and you can also
witness that particular event so
although you cannot do anything to the
event you can only remember it as a
third-person perspective so you can see
an event unfold in front of you you see
yourself and folding in front of you but
you cannot participate into it and
that's the main problem with episodic
memory so you can view you can
consciously feel the event but not
change it in any way and that is why
this time travel has a limitation so you
can travel back but cannot do anything
do not disturb anything into it and so
that is what is episodic memory whether
the semantic memory you have
it contains general and world knowledge
so basically all knowledge is about
where Africa is America
is what is Germany where is Germany who
was it who was Napoleon who's the Pope
who's the Prime Minister particular
country who's Barack Obama and all kind
of informations story who is basically
general world knowledge arithmetic rules
like 2+2 4 + 4 2 into 2 and all those
kinds of higher arithmetic rules past
tense of work like what is the past
tense of do what is the present tense of
any verb so run makes ran running that
kind of a thing so this kind of
information which is there which
basically is world knowledge basically
his knowledge is what is semantic memory
so quick distinction of these so
episodic memory has to deal with
personal experiences which is everything
which is personal to you which you are
involved in to which your self is the
concern is what is per se my episodic
memory where a semantic memory deals
with facts and concepts so it deals with
those information which is world
knowledge so you may be part of it you
may not be part of it but then this is a
fact this is something which everybody
shares and that is what type somatic
memories now when I say remember when it
is basically episodic memory so I'm
talking about the time and that leads to
the third definition or the third
quality of episodic memory but we'll
come to that in a minute so when I'm
saying remember when so remember when an
incident happened I'm actually asking to
Texas and episodic memory but I remem
ask you questions like remember what
what is a table what is a chair things
like what is an apple what is water and
all those kind of information so
remember what it is generally a concept
of semantic memory now episodic memories
are temporally organized and so it is
time analysis or time businesses so you
can see an event unfold in real time
when you're accessing an episodic memory
who is just like the Pangolin concept in
your facebook so there are certain
events put onto the timeline concept and
as I visit it you can see the event fold
in real-time that is what is the
episodic memory but then when you have
semantic memory it is related or it is
arranged in terms of meaning so meaning
the related arrangement is semantic
memory and so this is classic definition
or destination between the episodic and
semantic memory and so the several
evidences which were there to basically
prove these kind of memory systems exist
and one of the famous cases or one of
the famous evidences was provided by
sagittal in 1996 and so he studied a
particular brain-damaged person a vein
damage patient called gene and we need
to studied this brain-damaged person
what he found out that a certain region
of the brain specifically inhibited
episodic memory but it didn't inhabit
the semantic memory so this person was
able to access emetic memory tell about
facts about the world knowledge but
personally means this person could not
remember back another evidence which was
provided for this distinction of
episodic semantic memory was by tulving
in 1989 where he looked at cerebral
blood flow and he looked at cerebral
blood flow when a person was accessing
semantic memory and when he was
accessing in episodic memory and he
found out this cerebral blood flow that
was measured through a PT scan they were
different
so basically different kind of blood
flows exist in different regions of the
brain and so that is what the third
thing is different brain regions are
involved with the semantic and episodic
memories so the blood flow was different
all not only the flow the regions of the
brain were all so different from cement
can a piece OD memory so now we come to
know that the semantic memory is a huge
store it has a lot of information
arranged on to it right a huge capacity
now from every system is a huge capacity
because the world knowledge that you
have is a huge you learn everything
every someday every day you learn
something or that or a huge amount of
knowledge today so how are they
organized what is the way in which this
is organized and so several debates were
coming up there were several
propositions of how they were organized
so in the basis of that the whole idea
of semantic models of semantic knowledge
were proposed now one of the primary
things that we have thing is that
researchers working in the field of
artificial intelligence and computer
science who were modeling memory back in
the 87 80s and 90s those people they
wanted to build a common sense knowledge
system a system which has common sense
which can explain common-sense things
like how to do something how to open a
laid-off jar so how does the system like
this operate because common sense exists
from world knowledge only and so they
were thinking of designing a model now
what they said is that with a lot of
knowledge that we have the kind of
knowledge that we have we have a lot of
implicit knowledge hidden within the
kind of knowledge that we have which we
are not aware of
now take the example of a shampoo bottle
now if you look at a shampoo bottle and
if you look at the directions that it
says it says that hair take a little bit
apply rinse wash and repeat so if a
robot is given this to do if a computer
is given to do this what it will do is
it will keep on doing this cycle of
wetting the hair taking a little bird
shampoo putting it on raising it washing
it and repeating it till the bottle is
finished but then with most of us that
is not what we do we tend to stop after
one or two days and we
on continuing so where is the knowledge
the implicit knowledge of stopping after
one or two rains is is where does it
come from what how it is an inn and so
that particular store or that particular
idea of arrangement was what was people
looking at how is this idea or this
implicit knowledge where is it stored
with the world knowledge because one all
it says that you repeat so how many
times should repeat that is the other
question so implicit knowledge in
everyday routine informed you to know a
lot of things and a lot of other things
which you don't know that you know but
you take it for granted
so knowledge of language has an
associate great deal of implicit
knowledge also things like common things
like this certain other implicit
knowledge for example when I say the the
dragon had a liver now when I say a
dragon had liver you do not have to go
to check the whole idea of what a dragon
is or the whole structure of a dragon go
to a museum and find out whether it has
or not you know the dragon is the kind
of members in most mammal tends to have
liver and so it can be generalized so
this is implicit knowledge that if men
here have or birds like dragon had liver
so the dragon also had liver and so this
is implicit knowledge and so people
wanted to test how is this impressive
knowledge actually arranged so one of
the other reasons for making the
inferences or making thinking about or
modeling presenting models of increase
acknowledge of semantic memory was how
was the mental representations of
various knowledge arranged so we could
also wanted to know when a fact or a
knowledge is stored in a memory system
what is the way in which these
represented representations are stored
another interesting thing that was
happening is that how are they accessed
what is the speed of accessing so
basically questions like this were asked
that named
which has first letter L and name
quickly words which held the fourth
letter L for example the first word
could be livid and the LA and so words
with first letter L and the third letter
is L Cal q+ and so or the seventh letter
word l now if i ask you to name the
number of words which are with first
letter L and there were number of words
which are third letter a fourth letter L
you will end up telling me more words
which have first letter L and then the
number of words which are the seventh or
third or fourth or fifth letter L why
because this shows the speed with which
of how many words you can retrieve can
actually tell you how is the mental
dictionary organized
so basically mental definition is then
organized with the first letter
remember the metaphor that we used in
the bookshelf so basically the first
letter of Alice in Wonderland that al is
how it is arranged so a is LS and so you
will find a lot of it and so Alice in
Wonderland is arranged with Al the first
two letters and this is how this things
really works so basically then several
models are proposed of the semantic
memory and we look into a few models of
semantic memory which are here we'll
look into couple of models we'll also
look at how these modules compare with
each other and how one appreciates one
model goes ahead and cancels or
basically adds on to the limitation of
the other model and how a semantic
memory arrange so basically it was the
heretical semantic model was the first
model and so this model does a number of
things it tries to tell us how limited
database is arranged for the huge
knowledge so how is the database for a
huge knowledge that we have is arranged
and or basically the number of knowledge
that we have the number of facts and
knowledge and things semantic things
that we have how they are array also any
model of
semantic memory should be made in such a
way that it should not store redundant
things right things like let's say a dog
has four leg right and a cat has four
leg and let's say any other animal has
four leg so when I say that so each time
when I present a dog has four leg cat
has four like animal has four leg
so basically it should not be repeated
this for like the idea that this
particular kind of concept this
particular kind of object has four legs
should not be repeated with each
instance which means that the idea that
most mammals because anything which
falls under the members should have a
four leg issue bannin is such a way that
the higher category or the the idea that
any particular item within a category
should have four leg and the support leg
should be at the top of the feature at
the top level so if I am thinking of a
hierarchical semantic model which means
that knowledge is arranged in terms of
hierarchy any knowledge in Turing in
terms of hierarchy the top level
hierarchy should have these facts
because anything under that hierarchy
should have four like so lion tiger and
all kind of
members I'm talking about all follow
under the animal category or the mammal
category and so the the model should
remain in such a way that the mammal
category should have in inbuilt the idea
that it has four legs so basically that
kind of thing is dance and what it does
is it preserves something called
cognitive economy which where the
properties and facts are stored in the
highest level possible so basically if a
particular category if a particular
structure is designed in such a way that
properties and facts of the category
anything which falls in the category and
the main facts of those category should
be at the highest level and then within
that you will have lower levels on to it
and so the first model of semantic
memory was proposed by someone called
Collins and Quillin and they tested the
idea the semantic memory is analogous to
a network of connected ideas so what
koalas and Quillin they said is that
basically semantic memory is something
so semantic memory is basically an
arrangement of network
of connected ideas so they define that
any word our concept is arranged in
terms of nodes and pointers towards now
so these are two nodes this is one node
node one and this is node 2 so then two
concepts two words are related to each
other through a node and the junction or
the connection between two nodes is
prevented by a pointer so people who are
familiar with programming or C
programming C++ programming they are
familiar with this idea now this in
terms of programming this is a memory
location space which the computer
provides you and the pointer points how
to memory location spaces are basically
connected in terms of the hierarchical
model by Collins and Colin what it says
is that this is the memory area our
memory allocation or this is the node
for a particular word and this is the
node for a particular word and so if two
words are there then they have different
different memory location or different
different structures or different
different places are located in the
semantic memory and they are connected
by a pointer which points from the
highest node to the lowest node so
basically then what they said is the
model contains of consists of nodes in
this case what the concepts and each
node is connected to a related note by
means of a pointers and that is what I
was also telling you so this is the node
let's say this is the node for any kind
of dog so maybe German Shepherd this is
the node for a dog and so what happens
is these two nodes are connected because
within dog you will have German Shepherd
and within the German Shepherd also you
can have another node which is different
kind of
Shepard's which would be there and so
what happens is within dog the German
Shepherd will fall and within the German
Shepherd there will be others nodes also
within the dog category there will be
other nodes which are there so I will
have a per million node also and so on
and so forth so what is the fact here
this is how information is stored and
the dog will be again following under
the mammals node the node for mammal and
so on and so forth so we'll come to that
in a in a minute so basically that is
what their idea is that this is how our
arrangement is nodes and then connection
of nodes now there's a note that
corresponds to given what our concept
together with the pointers to other
nodes to which the first node is
connected constitutes of semantic memory
so basically semantic memory is this
kind of a structure and this kind of a
structure that I'm was talking about if
I know to a lower note kind of a thing
is called the semantic memory Network so
semantic network is the network of
mammal then following to dog and then
following to a German Shepherd this is a
network but say dog and German Shepherd
within each other is what is node node
to node connection and the pointers are
the pointing or what leads to what kind
of a thing so that is what this says and
so the collection of node associated
with all the words and concepts are
called the semantic Network
so let's look into this particular thing
so quickly look into this as you can see
here I will first wrap this thing here
quickly the whatever is written here to
show you what is there and so this is a
classic network that I was talking about
and so as you can see here what you see
here is a very small network and so as
you see this is the network of vehicle
under
a car falls under which truck falls and
as you can see the vehicle has several
properties which most vehicles which
follow under the vehicle note would have
and these properties are moves around it
means fuel it's man-made so car is also
vehicle so it has by default it has
moves around needs fuel and man-made
these are the properties of the node
remember the cognitive economy that we
talked about and so by putting these
three features at the top node which is
this is called the superordinate node
and this is called the subordinate node
so proudly named node is a node higher
than a particular node of concern and
super and and sub node is a node which
follows under the super ordinate node so
these properties then by default should
be a property of any member or the
vehicle and so when I talk about and
this is the link that is there and this
is the node so this is the pointer that
I was talking about and so we the
vehicle will have these three features
at the feature of any vehicle and so
these these features should also be in
cars where I talk about car cause car
also moves around Carlos who needs fuel
Carlos is man-made and when I talk about
car it has four wheels has an engine in
a window and so within the car node but
then all vehicles may not have four
wheels because our two wheeler is also a
vehicle so it may not have four wheels
but it moves around so these features
are common so these features are common
features to any item which is here but
features which are here may not be here
and the four wheels engine in window and
within the car then they have two more
nodes one is the truck node car follows
a truck and then I have a variety of car
which is the sports car it runs very
fast it is adjustable so I'll have a
sports car a sedan and so on and so
forth which fall on the corner also you
will find out this is this is a sub node
and this is the superordinate node so
any feature of the car will always be
here so it always supports car will have
four wheels will also have windows and
engines but then every car will not run
fast and so this kind of a reverse
pointer or this kind of a reverse
matching is not true but forward
matching is always true also truck is
kind of a car which has four wheels but
it special tall and German highway
and transport loads or something which
doesn't this note doesn't have so
they're separate with each other but
then the UH truck will always have four
wheels it will have an engine it will
have windows onto it but two more
features of it which may not be
consistent with the car
and all of them will have these four
features so basically this is how this
is the arrangement of the quillion and
Collins model of semantic memory he says
there is a network of nodes and these
network of nodes are connected by
pointers and so one network leads to the
other
also facts we just told it the highest
network which is the superordinate node
so the highest node is called the
superordinate node super ordinate node
and the one which is beside it is called
the subordinate or the subordinate node
so features which are at the
superordinate node will always be shared
by features of the subordinate or
feature so super ordinate is shared by
features of the subordinate but in
features a subordinate may or may not be
shared by the superordinate node so this
is how : in Chileans define the idea of
semantic memory so they tested the
principle of cognitive economy in their
model and as I said one of the things
that needs to be tested with most models
of semantic memory is the idea of
cognitive economy that properties which
are the highest properties which are the
highest placing in model it should have
the it should have the higher the basic
concepts or all properties of the
concept so words and concepts should be
always at the highest note all
superordinate know so they state the
principle of cognitive economy with this
model and they reasoned that closer in
fact the store to a particular node the
less time it should take to verify a
particular property so if a particular
item a particular fact or a concept is
stored very close to another node very
close to another concept it should take
less time to verify then if it is stored
far away and they tested this particular
thing so they reported that people took
less time to respond to sentences those
representations should spend two levels
a Cannady is a but then to
representation which
spencey levels so then let's look at
this particular how this arrangement is
so basically I have the arrangement of
animal and within animal we have mammals
and birds and within birds
I have the Kennedy the parrot and so on
and so forth so when I'm verifying and
so they said that since if cognitive
economy is to be preserved if words
which are concepts were higher-order
concepts should be stored above a lower
order concept if that is what the idea
of formative economy is because all
properties of word has to be shared by
Kennedy and our property of animal has
to be shared by what if that is how the
arrangement is then people should take
less time in verifying Kennedy is a bird
then verifying Kennedy is an animal and
that is what it actually happened with
them so they took that people they saw
that people took less time to respond to
sentences representation of span two
levels
Henry's a bird then for presentation
which was planning three levels so this
is one and two level and this is three
level so basically cognitive economy is
preserved here also the model was called
the hierarchical semantic Network model
of semantic memories of this particular
thing because what I have is the
higher-order concepts or the concepts
which have basic features which every
items on that particular concept or
every item within that concept should
have should be the highest level and
within that will have other items and so
cons the properties of one chef will be
shared by any item which is under that
particular concept
now the nodes in the model are organized
in hierarchy as I said they're in the
top node then there is a another node
and then there is another node and known
and all appointed by all are connected
by a pointers now a very good example of
thinking of it is think of your windows
when you think about your windows you
have this tree structure and so there
are folders within folders within
folders within folders if you have ever
worked with the Linux system you will
find
that there is a part that we talk about
PA th and this part is basically how
nodes are connected so because if you
had so let's say there is a in in Linux
you have the first part a slash root and
then within that you have slash et Cie
and then you have something something
and then within this you have generally
have STC and within STC you have us ad
which is the user and then you have the
home and then you have your desktop so
if you want to reach your desktop you
have to go through this part and this is
how the semantic network is also
connected so root is the one which is
the highest level concept with the
superordinate concept within that the
etc' is there which is the subordinate
concept within that the STC is there
which is another store which is there
within that user is there within that
home is there and with that you are a sa
and which is basically your desktop
similarly they have a system like this
so then most nodes have superordinate
nodes and subordinate nodes above a
particular node you superordinate just
as we saw in this particular thing in
this particular example so what we had
is vehicle is a superordinate node and
truck is a subordinate node or sports
car is a subordinate
also there is what is what it has been
saying here now with a model like this
where we have this kind of superordinate
subordinate node and things which are
saved in this way a good experiment was
done by Marin skin wealth in 71 and they
reasoned beautifully they gave this
reason that if related words are stored
close on one network and they are
connected to one another in a semantic
Network then when one node is energized
energy shift we should actually spread
to really tear related notes one reason
is that spreading activation the idea
that exciting is particularly network
along a connection of network in the
semantic Network so let us try to
understand what this is so we have the
animal node and within the animal node
will have something called the
mammals and within them birds and
mammals will have let's say a parrot and
another one is let's say a Robin and
within the mammal we have a tiger and we
have a lion so what he says is that when
and so word since birds and members are
not connected to each other but then
what he says is that when some energy I
want some energy is when somebody is
accessing their animal node this
activation that follows to the bird
should should basically go ahead and and
excite both parrot and Robin at the same
time or with so Robin may not be
connected to Tiger in any way but then
if they are connected in some way
if these nodes because some kind of
connection would be there between Robin
and Tiger of course very difficult to
explain what it is but they they might
would be kind coming from animals and so
the um kind of connection would be
spread between them so when I energize
this animal or when somebody starts
traveling from this animal down to Birds
both this node will be activated right
and so within the birds you will have
colorful words non colorful words and
within the colorful and non colorful
even as a talkative words non talkative
words and small and so forth so what
they said is that when an excitation
moves down a node like this what would
happen is this excitation will not only
spread to one node particularly also
spread to excitation spreads along
connection of Nagina
semantic network so this excitation
would also go ahead and connect to tiger
so tiger will be weakly excited but then
it won't be excited now how Robin is
connected Tiger is very difficult to
look at but then there will be certain
members which may be related to Robin in
some way or parrot in some way and so
that excitation will always be there or
connected there and that is why they
said this is because we have always
found out that when I say Queen people
say King when I say bread
people say butter now when you look into
it bread and butter they are two
different things
king and queen are two different
concepts which altogether Queen is from
the female category working is from the
male category but Queen and King are
related to each other and this relation
is basically can only be explained
through the idea of this spreading
activation what happens is and an
activation when a node is energized this
energy also spreads no it doesn't only
go to the node which is subset with it
so we'll have reptiles also for example
so when animal is excited reptile nodes
also get excited onto it so kin Queen
Queen although being this is female and
male and so on top of it if we look into
the node of animals so within animals we
have million female within king and
queen so although they are different but
some kind of activity relate them and so
this was an basic example to show that
these river nodes are connected to each
other now there are several limitations
to this particular the hierarchical
model of semantic memory one is about
cognitive economy as a Conrad in 72 1972
they found that people are no faster to
verify sentences like a shark can move
then a fish can move or and anyone can
go so what they found out is that even
if we span so if we span let's say two
levels or if we spend four levels on a
network so let's say it's a four level
network four nodes so when we verify a
sentence which is four not far from the
subordinate superordinate node people
take almost the same time and so this
idea of kinetic on a-- me was not
preserved by this hierarchical semantic
network another problem was the
structure of the hierarchy itself so
ribbon rips and sha'ban Smith they
showed that participants were faster to
verify a pig is a mammal
nt verify a pig is an animal so
basically they quickly identified pig is
an animal then Pig is a mammal now if
you look into it animal is the high
note and then within that you have
mammal and within that you have several
other things let's say two more nodes
are there and then you have the pig
which is actually a member so when
people verify Pig is an animal which is
let's say that it is directly connected
here so we have one node and two nodes
so when people are verifying one two and
three and where people are verifying two
levels and people are verifying three
levels of people verify three levels
faster than two levels and so and this
is what the thing would look like so
they found out that this idea of
hierarchical structure was violated by
the hierarchical network model also
typicality effect was another reason or
another limitation of the identical
symmetric model what it says is that
Birds which were typical for example
Robin parrot was of a sparrow
these were faster in verification so
when people verified a Robin is a word
or a parrot is a bird they're faster to
say yes verifying the sentence then to
verify sentences like ostrich is a bird
or a turkey is a bird or a hen is a bird
if you look into it both hand turkey and
ostrich are all birds but then people
took more time to verify these sentences
now although if we look into it
ostriches and turkeys both have the same
kind of structure the same kind of
features as Robin or a parrot would have
but when we are verifying this when
people verify this kind of a structure
and better people verify this kind of a
typical versus non typical instance of a
particular concept people are more prone
to verifying the more typical car or
instance than not driven typical so the
idea that all elements of a concept are
not arranged or not verified in the same
manner and so this is typical defect and
so they've found that problem with
hierarchical semantic model so since
these were the problem that were there
the violations which are there another
model called the feature comparison
model was actually proposed which would
go ahead and solve some of the problems
which the
a model of hierarchical symmetrical
Network was actually doing so what was
the model like so split so Marin rapes
they proposed an alternative model to
the hierarchical semantic model which
was called the feature comparison model
or semantic memory assumption was the
meaning of any word or concept it
consists of set of features are elements
called features and features come in two
types so he said what they said is that
semantic memory is not arranged in terms
of some kind of a structure or some kind
of hierarchical structure but they're
arranged in in in a in a way in which
there are certain features so there are
two basic features that we talked about
so when I look at a concept item for
example I'm looking at dog so the dog
has two kinds of features one is called
the defining features of a dog and then
there is a characteristic features so
facts like it has four it barks it has
four legs it has a tail which bags are
defining features of a dog because most
dogs will have them and then there are
characteristic features which some dogs
they have and some dogs may not have for
example there is a dog that that's out
there which doesn't bark and then there
is a dog which has very less steel for
example you have a dog which has no tail
at all and then you have a dog which is
a huge tail or there is a dog which have
or think of a dog which has three legs
on it so how do we accommodate for that
so that kind of a thing is there and so
most dogs whatever they have is the
defining feature and some dogs may have
features which are extra which are
called characteristic features and so
this is what it is so the meaning of a
word or concept consists of set of
elements called features and we shall
generally come up two types defining
features features must be present in
every example so every dog should have
them four legs barking our tail or
greeby your man's best friend is what
most dogs should have and so these are
the defining features and characteristic
features are those features which are
usually not necessarily which are
usually but not necessarily present for
example barking as I said or other
features example big tail or facts like
drooping years-long teens these kind of
features maybe there may not be there or
a glossy skin
may not be there or the height like that
person Bernards are dogs which are very
high and Chihuahua is a dog which is
looks like a cat and so they may not
have the same feature so for them this
is the kind of network they thought
about this is the kind of feature
related fact that they thought about and
so if you look at attribute or feature
of a model example if I'm looking at a
Robin and I'm looking at a bird so there
are two level concepts bird will follow
or birds are the super ordinate node and
the Robin is the subordinate so if you
look into it both are physical object
both are living both animate both are
feathered
so these are the features which are the
features which are defining so any bird
will have any borders physical organism
well as living is animate and his
feathered but then this particular thing
is called the characteristic feature of
a Robin because most bird may not be red
feathered and already bested and so this
is the characteristic feature and all
these are the defining features because
defining features is something which
most of the elements of this concept
should have whereas if you look into the
comparison with hierarchical model
helical model says animal is a bird
which has feathers is a Robin which has
red breasted and so this kind of thing
this network has a problem because they
should share so if the word has feathers
and Robin should have feathers but red
district that is the kind of problem
which is there and so this model has
this problem which is solved by my
feature model or the new feature model
of semantic memory so what it says is
that when why does the verifying
sentence problem really occurs or how do
sentence verification happens according
to the feature network model or the
feature model according to the feature
model the first step is the presentation
of an item so when I show you a new item
there's our test presentation is there
and we retry features as
to north and so basically c1 is the
defining feature here and C 0 is the
characteristic feature of a particular
thing so I present us st. Bernard to you
and I ask you to verify this whether
this is a mammal or not whether st.
Bernard is a ml or not and so when you
look into it it's a stage one you look
at the characteristic feature in the
defining feature of strain but not so
what happens is initially the first step
is to look at all the features or gather
all the features then compare X to the
criteria C naught and C 1 if X is less
than C naught which is the
characteristic feature which is that I'm
sorry the defining feature if it doesn't
has a defining feature for example it
works and so st. but not doesn't work
let's say then I can move this way so C
naught is the defining feature C 1 is
the characteristic feature and so if C
naught X is less than C naught or C
naught is greater than X then I move
here executes a negative response and
say it is false so if I have a cow a
calf and I am trying to say to you that
this is a st. but not and the calf goes
maomao and doesn't say bow-bow which is
what a dog shouldn't say this is a
defining feature of barking and so I can
execute a negative response saying this
is false otherwise there could be other
things that if I can also compare the
characteristic feature or if the match
is not of even of a characteristic
feature I can or even if some
characteristic feature matches so medium
in the may not be defining but a
characteristic feature for example I
said there's a dog which doesn't bark
but it loads like a dog it has a glossy
screen it has a tail which wags and it
looks more or less like a dog droopy has
all those characteristic features are
there and so if it matches even though
if the characteristic features matches
and executes a prostitute responds and
say it is true but in cases where my
response the response that I get by
comparing the characteristic and
defining features is in between the
characteristic and defining features so
the amount of if the amount of defining
features is very high I say yes I am I
new item is a part of this particular
list but then if it is very low I say it
is not part of a list so if it doesn't
have a defining feature like say false
if it has very high amount of defining
features or some very high
characteristic feature I say it is yes
but if it is in a mediocre range if it
is hiding high having neither a very
high characteristic feature nor very
less than a defining feature I go ahead
and do that I compare the defining
features then so defining features
doesn't come into play in in comparison
there in the feature models until then
unless it falls the comparison of
features falls in the medical range when
the characteristic feature is is is
looked at so first step is I gather all
the features then I look at the
characteristic feature of a particular
item which has been presented in the
category characterized feature is very
less than matching the characteristic
feature that the new item has matching
to the concept is very low I'll say no
it is not part of this particular
category if it is very high I say it is
a part of it in circumstances and the
characteristic feature is somewhat
madacorp it lies between the defining
and the characteristic features or not
too much of characteristic features
present but it has some characteristic
features I go ahead and compare the
defining features only the defining
features only if there is a match with
the defining feature execute of to
response or I execute a false response
and this is the two-stage characteristic
feature comparison for semantic
categories so again very quickly what I
do is if a new instance comes in first I
compare the characteristic feature hi
comparison of erect feature or high
number of characteristic features
present I say this instant belong or
this incident or this item belongs to my
category low amount of characteristic
feature present I say it doesn't belong
if the amount of characteristic feature
present is somewhat in between low and
high I go ahead and look at the defining
features or if the defining features is
high I say a match is their defining
features in low I say execute a negative
response and it is false so feature
comparison model white is good because
it can explain some other or
shortcomings of the earlier model first
typicality effect sentences like a Robin
is a bird I
verified more quickly than turkeys about
because Robin becomes more typical
example of birds then thought to share
more characteristic features with the
bird so Robin stares although it has a
number a number of defining features but
when you actually look at Robin it has a
lot of characteristic features add-on
features with the bird and so they are
verified much quicker but when I look at
a turkey when I look at an ostrich they
don't have a number of characteristic
features so a stage two verification has
to be looked at but what happens is the
comparison with Robin is only a stage
one it has a lot of characteristic
features which is of the word and so it
is cat categorize and it's easy to
verify Robin is a bird also category
size effect what it says is the category
goes higher so if there is a subordinate
superordinate category and within that
there is subordinate category if the
category is small and the characteristic
feature list of characteristic features
will be small and so verification will
take less time but if a category is huge
if I am talking about mammals and there
will be all kind of members which is
there and so if I am talking about a
system like that what will happen is the
verification time will be more and so as
categories grow as the number of
categories grow as the kind of
verification category is huge it will
take more and more time this is called
the category size effect now what is the
criticism to that the criticism to this
theory is that there is no existence of
defining features what is a defining
feature nobody knows and so there is no
there is no existence for what a
defining feature should be suppose a
bird has clipped wings will it be called
the word so what could be called a
defining feature is not very forthcoming
here or not very present here so in this
lecture we looked at what is semantic
memory we looked at how they are
arranged we looked at the episodic
semantic distinction and we also looked
at the two basic modules the
hierarchical semantic model and feature
comparison model and how these model
compare to each other and they go ahead
and sort of complement each other in the
next lecture we will look at some other
models of semantic memory and also
something of how semantics may be
really works thank you
[Music]
you